arquímides se está vaciando a su tina de
baño por cada dos minutos que pasan se
deben siete galones de agua cuál de las
siguientes funciones puede representar
la cantidad de galones de agua en la
tina y como función de los minutos que
han transcurrido t y nos dan estas
opciones de aquí así que bien empecemos
empecemos haciendo una pequeña gráfica
y esta me dije que va a ser mi eje del
agua y voy a poner por acá mi eje del
tiempo y es también el tiempo bien
latina comienza con alguna cantidad de
agua que no me especifican pero tengo
que asumir que esa cantidad es positiva
así que voy a llamar a esa cantidad a
cero así que a cero es galones iniciales
de agua galones
iniciales
de agua
de agua es la cantidad de agua con la
que empieza la tina y si yo dejo pasar 2
minutos de hecho el tiempo está medido
en minutos
minutos
y el agua la cantidad de agua esta
medida en galones
solo para tener nuestras unidades claras
entonces yo sé que si dejó pasar dos
minutos de que se empieza a vaciar la
tina entonces aquí tengo un minuto y por
acá tendría dos minutos
2 entonces no sé dónde estaré porque no
sé con cuánta aguante sé pero sé que se
habrán perdido 7 galones de agua así que
digamos si aquí estoy en 2 entonces este
punto aquí tendría altura a 0 menos 7 de
modo que la gráfica de cómo se va a
drenando el agua sí supongo que se drena
de un modo constante se ve algo así
donde la idea es que eso fuera una línea
recta que pasa por el punto que está en
0,0 y por el punto 2,07 bien entonces
esa es la gráfica de cómo se va vaciando
la tina
para poder escribir una función que
describa cómo se va vaciando la tina una
buena idea sería considerar la tasa de
cambio de esta gráfica lo que significa
eso es que tanto está cambiando el eje
vertical por un cambio en el eje
horizontal que tanto cambia la cantidad
de agua dependiendo de la cantidad del
tiempo y eso frecuentemente se conoce
como la pendiente de esta línea recta
entonces vamos a escribir esto el cambio
la tasa de cambio del agua entre el
tiempo puede escribir este triangulito
que es la letra griega delta mayúscula y
significa cambio en así que el cambio en
la cantidad de agua dividido entre el
cambio en cambio en la cantidad de
tiempo bien entonces yo sé que si el
tiempo cambia en dos unidades y pasa de
que empieza a vaciarse el agua a dos
minutos si en la cantidad del tiempo
cambia en dos unidades entonces la
cantidad de agua cambia en menos siete
unidades porque estoy perdiendo agua por
lo tanto el cambio es
estoy perdiendo agua y entonces el
cambio entre el cambio en t es igual a
menos 7 medios les recuerdo esto
generalmente se conoce como la pendiente
de esta recta y eso ya me permite
escribir una ecuación general porque
porque ya que tengo esto lo que puedo
hacer es decir bueno quiero averiguar la
cantidad de agua en algún tiempo t pues
empecé con una cantidad de agua a cero
y luego por cada minuto que pasa tenía
que sumar menos siete medios por la
cantidad de tiempo ese es el cambio que
está teniendo pero como estoy sumando
menos siete medios es lo mismo que
escribir menos vamos a ponerlo con otro
color menos siete medios
de el tiempo por cada minuto que pase
por cada dos minutos que pasen yo pierdo
siete galones o por cada minuto que pase
yo pierdo siete medio galones
bien entonces tengo esta ecuación de
aquí y si ustedes recuerdan la forma de
las ecuaciones punto pendiente quizás
recuerden que una ecuación es de la
forma y es igual a mx + b y que esto
escribe una recta con pendiente m y
intersección con el eje y b pero en este
caso no tengo ya mi eje x tengo eje a y
ft eje vertical y eje horizontal por lo
tanto esta ecuación se escribiría como a
la cantidad de agua es igual a la
pendiente de la recta que es menos siete
medios observen que es una recta que
tiene pendiente negativa es una función
decreciente más perdón por el tiempo el
tiempo es la variable independiente en
este caso más la intersección con el eje
vertical que sería a cero
es importante señalar que esto solo
funcionó porque la tina siempre se drena
a la misma velocidad siempre se drenan 7
galones de agua por cada 2 minutos que
pasan si esa tasa cambiará si este
número de aquí no fuera una constante no
podría describir esto con una línea
recta pero bueno si comparo las
ecuaciones las respuestas que me dan con
esta forma de la ecuación entonces notó
que la única que tiene la forma correcta
es esta de aquí por lo tanto yo creo que
esa es la respuesta correcta de hecho
puede descartar las demás sin tener que
haber hecho todo esto por ejemplo la
primera respuesta cuando te vale cero a
vale cero también y entonces me describe
una tina que está vacía en el primer
instante pero para que vaciaría
arquímides rutinas y de por si yo estaba
vacía por lo tanto eso no tiene sentido
por otro lado esta ecuación a pesar de
que cuando te vale 0 latina si tendría
100 galones de agua me describe una tina
que se está llenando esta es una
pendiente positiva por lo tanto sería
una línea que se vería algo así y es una
tina que se va llenando conforme pasa el
tiempo hay más y más agua en la tina por
lo tanto ésta tampoco sirve
esta es la opción que tenía y ésta que
me describe pues de nuevo me escribe una
tina que tiene 20 galones cuando te vale
0 pero de nuevo se están aumentando la
cantidad de galones y de hecho está
pendiente ni siquiera tiene algo que ver
con la pendiente que tenía por lo tanto
esta ecuación tampoco puede ser así que
la única función que puede representar
la cantidad de galones de agua en la
tina como una función de los minutos que
han transcurrido es esta función de aquí
precisamente